hello ladies and gentlemen I am Ryan the
right and I am Katie the dupois I don't
like it that way
well no it sounds like a horrible sex
position the du Bois
yeah actually it sounds like a French
sex position yeah yeah you know good for
you too bye guys
Marvel's daredevil season 2 official
trailer the New York Comic Con 1 I'm
like a month late on this I'm excited
waiting for someone who's seen
[Music]
this aggressiveness
[Music]
the show is so cool I love this show
[Music]
[Music]
that's I'm good to you oh yeah
House kitchen needs to die before it can
be reborn
[Music]
what's getting around about new people
you've helped me
[Music]
impressive take care of them
I need to be the man this city needs
[Music]
justice is a matter of asking the right
people the right questions in the right
to avoid and forgive me for being blunt
yeah now we're season two way to say no
is a beg beg beg no Hank no he's saying
it the same beg or bang
I don't know cuz he was loading a gun
yeah he says bang and he doesn't pull
the trigger instead he's like bang yeah
or he's he's punishing someone he says
beg I am so psyched to see Jon Bernthal
Baron thought I don't forgot how his
last name goes anyway loved him in the
walking dead a loved him and Wolf of
Wall Street
loved him in fury he is the perfect
choice for the new Punisher so [ __ ]
stoked it looks good but it does look
like it has a different tone they know
what the stakes are at this point that's
it yeah some of the characters were able
to be like oh this is just like oh we
need to help the community or whatever
but now everybody knows how big the
stakes are the stakes are the city the
whole city dynamics with Punisher and
daredevil are gonna be so [ __ ]
interesting to watch because Punisher he
murders he tortures he's like how would
I put it super villain he's like a
villain to villains basically like he's
really he's terrifying to both sides of
the he's he's is the home person he's a
loner he's in between good and bad
I'm gonna have sex with me why why did
that you there punish me
Wow okay that's something you need to
communicate you know I can't tell my
girlfriend that I'm really gay whoa but
you can tell her that you're like you
know a little tap neat a beloved edge
yeah it looks beautiful it's just
different enough not like you made a
brand new show
it looks like it's advanced which is
great I'm ready honey I'm ready - I'm
ready - now's always the blonde I was
telling you like oh the blonde the one
you were like the brunette and I was
like no baby when you remember Jessica
from Tru Bloods then yeah I can look it
up babe can you look it up my computer's
not worried Deborah Ann Woll
okay I wanted to remember who that was
she's beautiful
she's actually thank goodness she's in
this series because I think she's the
bridge between Daredevil and foggy
character because I think casting wise
it's their little unmatched in my
opinion so I'm glad that she's there to
sort of bridge the tones of these
characters at first I didn't like her
then me eventually yeah she grew they
all sort of got into into the flow a
little bit the season yeah it's towards
the end of the season their characters
seem to serve a lot more purpose we
can't give away two reveals and stuff
but when [ __ ] really starts hitting the
fan that fans just start spinning [ __ ]
everywhere that doesn't actually happen
at the end of the series that was a
metaphor that was a metaphor
using poop as a metaphor wonder how long
they'll keep the law firm
Chirag cuz they definitely didn't do
like any you know work like there is
maybe a quarter of an episode
I just wonder how there was one episode
rule is all dedicated a law work that
one with the woman's insurance and not
wanting to move out in the apartment
kind of that I was so bored that's the
only episode where I was like I got
bored a lot in that episode see I
learned a trick I need a gap to gather
more female subs and the best way to get
a female's attention is you ignore them
oh wow so should we just like ignore the
girl all the girls are no good yes pay
attention eyes we're just gonna ignore
you
Thank You thingies come on if you guys
are new to the channel a few girls or
near the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects by clicking this button
above my head or not okay Catherine you
address her as Catherine du Bois falling
around Facebook Instagram Twitter
that's why don't you know you're ugly
and you're fat you don't deserve
happiness
baby I'm hooking female subs in right
now no women like compliments you're
beautiful and you're awesome wait wait
why yeah woman like compliments yes
women like combo baby baby are you
hearing that [ __ ] baby yes she's just
she's playing along with Katie right now
it's funny joke
they're like good compliments like I
don't know your nose hair is clean thank
you it is thank you very much good job
and I love that you get to vote